Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera.
Bellezza:
io provo a ragionare
intorno al sostantivo.
Bellezza è sicuramente Naomi Campbell,
e bellezza è Claudia Schiffer,
che sono i riferimenti dei boomer come me.
Bello è Johnny Depp in Jack Sparrow,
poi nei Pirati dei Caraibi.
Io non rifuggo la bellezza,
è più lei che rifugge me.
Ma io non sono timido.
Anzi, io sono così a mio agio
con la bellezza
perché ci convivo da tutta una vita.
Questo non è vero,
però la frase mi piaceva così tanto
che alla fine ho deciso di tenerla.
Tra l'altro, stamani,
lo sapete cosa sono andato a fare qui,
nel vostro paese di Putignano?
Sono andato a tagliarmi i capelli
da Domenico Santoro,
dall'istituzione proprio,
dal re del paese.
A proposito di cose belle,
ecco Domenico è sicuramente
una cosa parecchio bella,
tanto non costa nulla usare
l'aggettivo qualificativo quanto si vuole.
Perciò lui è proprio un uomo "figa".
Ecco: per me "figa", ad esempio,
è l'opposto dell'idea
che ho io di una cosa bella.
Bello, Bellezza..
Gli aggettivi qualificativi più abusati
nelle nostre miserie quotidiane,
ad esempio per lasciarli solamente
riferiti alla bellezza fisica.
Che però secondo me c'è,
non è che non esista, non ci sia.
Figli e figlie, belli e belle,
saranno facilitati
nella carriera lavorativa,
e nelle relazioni sociali.
Finanche nelle amicizie,
e nel sorriso più o meno sincero
di un barista o di una commessa.
Questo è terribile?
Per me sì.
È qualcosa che mi scarnifica
un pezzo di me.
Però provando a dirlo,
e a fotografarlo questa sera insieme a voi
mi serve anche per oggettivizzarlo
e così iniziare a mettere la mano in tasca
per tirare fuori l'immagine e bruciarla.
L'immagine che però esiste:
ora non mi venite a dire
che non è reale la bellezza,
che è la questione, invece,
più reale del mondo.
E magari se ne va via veloce,
anche se su questo Alain Delon
non sarebbe d'accordo.
Quando mi hanno detto
che il tema sarebbe stato la bellezza,
io ho fatto la prima cosa
che non dovremmo mai fare,
cioè sono andato su Google
e ho cercato una definizione.
E Google dice che è "La qualità capace
di appagare l'animo attraverso i sensi".
È una balla, è una palla ed è una bugia.
Perché la bellezza non appaga niente.
La bellezza non è un atto masturbatorio,
ma è di vita.
Su masturbazione ride sempre qualcuno,
è bellissimo.
La bellezza è capace
di moltiplicare la vita.
Le questioni belle sconquassano,
creano casini nella banalità;
la bellezza riesce
a far maturare i frutti,
e a farti godere nel mangiarne.
La bellezza non è la foto: è l'atto,
e l'atto è sempre movimento.
E non appaga, ne chiama altri.
Come le parole, la lingua e i racconti.
Buonasera a tutte e a tutti.
Mi auguro che siate belli
e che siate belle.
Vi vedo solo parzialemnte,
ma quel poco che vedo mi piace,
"mi garba" come si dice dalle mie parti.
Ora, ricordatevi
che è solo grazie ai brutti
che i belli acquisiscono un senso.
Non scordatevi mai
di ringraziare i brutti,
perché la chiave del vostro
successo ce l'hanno loro,
che se un giorno sparissero
la vostra bellezza non vi sarebbe
più riconosciuta.
Detto questo, capito questo,
sorpassata l'età adolescenziale
io con la bellezza ho sempre avuto
una specie di rapporto ambivalente:
Secondo me è lei che mi deve riconoscere,
non il contrario.
Non indosso una camicia
dal matrimonio di un amico, molti anni fa.
Non indosso una giacca dal matrimonio
di quello stesso amico, tanti anni fa.
Tra l'altro, se fate un paragone
fra tutti gli speaker,
sono quello vestito
più di merda di tutti quanti.
Ma va bene, mi piace:
io mi muovo in questa maniera.
Sono attratto dalla bellezza
che sta negli anfratti,
negli angoli, nei caduti,
nei penultimi e negli ultimi,
nei fragili, nei vulnerabili,
i calpestati, gli addolorati,
i piegati, gli zoppi, gli impolverati.
Perché a loro si dice,
soprattutto, "siate forti":
ma loro lo sono già, forti.
È che chi lo dice
non vede quanto sono belli.
Perché chi resiste è, sempre,
bello da impazzire e da impazzare.
Gli strapasseri e le strapassere
dell'anima, dei sentimenti,
sono loro, i più belli di tutti.
E allora Scarlett Johansson come è?
È bella, eh.
ma è bella soprattutto quando risponde
ai giornalisti impertinenti
in conferenza stampa,
non so se l'avete mai vista,
quando rimette al centro
il lavoro di attrice,
e non i trucchi.
Sono i giornalisti
che ai colleghi uomini fanno domande
sull'interpretazione dei personaggi;
a lei fanno invece domande sulla dieta,
o sui capelli o sul fidanzato,
finanche sulle unghie,
Non sono arrivati alle mestruazioni
solo perché quelle sono innominabili
in certi ambienti pubblici.
Ma non in questo, però.
Mestruazioni!
Mestruazioni, sì!
La bellezza è quella di chi piange
per qualcosa che accade agli altri,
prima che a sé stessi.
Il dottor Volpi, che ho intervistato
all'Ospedale Maggiore di Parma,
durante il lockdown del 2020,
quello più duro.
Io ho fatto un giro fra gli ospedali
del centro e del nord Italia,
le terapie intensive.
Lui piange perché diceva
"faccio dieci morti al giorno".
E io gli chiedo: "Ma non viene,
dopo un po', la scorza?"
"Ma che scorza".
E nel frattempo, cercava
il fazzoletto in tasca.
Ed è bello perché non è
l'esibizione di un dolore,
ma è il racconto nonostante
il dolore che lo avvolge.
Volpi che a casa dormiva
nel lettone, insieme alla moglie,
ma tutto da un lato, rattrappito
e dandole la schiena,
Diceva "È 30 giorni
che non tocco un corpo caldo" -
perché aveva paura
di infettare la moglie -
e diceva " L'unico corpo caldo che tocco
è quello del mio chihuahua,
Perché non gli posso dire nulla,
e mi salta sulle ginocchia "
e allora c'era questo vecchio
che ci mimava l'atto dell'accarezzare
questo chihuahua invisibile,
di fronte a me in ospedale.
Vecchio, un'altra parola bella.
Il vecchio del villaggio
e delle città, i saggi.
Altro che anziani, certe parole
sono educazione alla distanza.
Chi ha lo zaino zeppo
di parole e di bellezza
è invece, secondo me, un grande vecchio.
Vecchia!
Mi sono innamorato
di questa parola al femminile.
Ora non tutte le vecchie sono belle,
ma quelle che ho incontrato
a Chernobyl, sì.
Eccola lì una.
I mariti erano morti per alcolismo,
il governo aveva detto "se bevete,
diventate immuni alle radiazioni".
Le donne non ci avevano creduto,
i mariti sì.
Oggi quelle donne sono vecchie,
e quanto sono belle e distanti
dall'esibizione scenografica del dolore
mentre in questo caso
mi stava per offrire delle patate,
coltivate in quella terra
contaminata dove lei viveva.
E poi i ciechi:
secondo me sono bellissimi
quelli che giocano a calcio.
Li ho incontrati
alle paralimpiadi di Londra:
Avete idea dei ciechi
che giocano a calcio?
Ma come fanno?
Si scontrano meno dei vedenti:
questo non lo so come facciano.
Stanno addirittura
con una benda sugli occhi
per essere sicuri
che proprio non possano vedere
nemmeno una piccola luce.
Fanno i dribbling,
e sono ciechi davvero, e non per finta:
non è un fatto di pensione.
E allora, belle sono secondo me
queste cose piccole,
le quotidiane costruzioni,
che resistere ha un senso presente;
ma lo acquisisce, soprattutto,
se il verbo lo mettiamo al futuro
e suona appunto, e non per caso,
come "costruire".
Bella è mia nonna Elsa -
che è una disobbediente,
e non appare nemmeno qui.
Eccola: bella, lo vedete com'è veloce?
Non sono venute nemmeno le mani,
continuava a muoverle più di me -
Mia nonna Elsa mi raccontava
il petting con mio nonno
da cui nacque mio zio,
il fratello maggiore del mio babbo.
Che quel racconto di mia nonna Elsa
era il suo modo per mettermi in guardia -
ero piccino -
ma era anche il suo modo per dirmi
che con la guardia abbassata, ogni tanto,
nascono le cose più belle.
"Comunque oh Saverio, petting
ma allora il tuo nonno secondo me
ci è andato troppo vicino,
perché tu vedrai
che sono rimasta incinta".
Ma siccome era comunque
un tempo di pregiudizi,
come è anche oggi ma prima ancora di più,
poi si sono dovuti sposare
in fretta e furia,
ma comunque due mesi gli ci sono voluti.
Perciò nove meno due fa sette,
e mio zio Mario, dicevano,
era nato settimino.
E le comari del paese, ignoranti,
andavano li e le dicevano:
"Ma che bel bambino, è grande!
Non sembra proprio di sette mesi"
È la mia nonna diceva:
"Infatti non è di sette mesi".
Quanto era bella mia nonna
che mi raccontava queste cose;
e io ero piccolino, non ero un gigante.
Soprattutto, quando sentivo lei
parlare di petting, io sparivo.
Ma nelle cose piccoline
ci stanno anche le storie grandi:
è il segreto dei piccoli,
e del fare spazio.
E questo, secondo me,
ha molto a che fare con il bello.
Le cose piccole, che fanno spazio.
Loro sono Andra e Tatiana.
Sono state deportate al campo
di concentramento di Auschwitz
all'età di sei e quattro anni.
In questo caso, dove è la bellezza?
La bellezza è anche quella sottratta,
quella che non c'è, quella che si nota
per la sua assenza.
Ora pensate al campo
di concentramento di Auschwitz,
e capirete perché
la bellezza è importante.
Perché senza, appare Birkenau.
Andra e Tatiana,
più di ogni altra persona,
mi hanno fatto capire
come certe parole siano belle
anche se raccontano cose brutte,
perché servono per farti
appiccicare addosso le cose brutte
perché tu non le scordi,
e gli altri non le ripetano.
La bellezza sta nel racconto
che queste due sorelle
hanno continuato a fare negli anni.
Io andai con loro al campo
di sterminio di Auschwitz,
e in questo caso eravamo in albergo -
ero io nella loro camera d'albergo -
E Tatiana che dice:
"Ma mica ci riprendi i piedi, vero?
Perché abbiamo le pantofole"
"Ah, vabbè; ma se ce le riprendi
tanto è uguale, no?"
E guarda Andra, e Andra le dice di sì.
Andra e Tatiana,
che sono due nonne in fondo,
e anche per principio.
E allora ecco le parole,
quelle capaci di restarti addosso.
"Barbecue", detto con mezzo
tono superiore da Tatiana,
"che tutte le volte che sento
l'odore di carne bruciata sul barbecue
ricordo l'odore dei corpi
che usciva dai camini di Auschwitz",
Mi dice 12 secondi
prima di scattare questa immagine.
Oppure un'altra parola,
completamente diversa:
"emorroidi".
Ora loro erano già grandi e libere,
però Tatiana si chiuse in bagno
e non voleva più uscire
perché il medico aveva il camice bianco,
come quello del non dottor Mengele,
quello che si portò via
anche il loro cuginetto Sergio.
Lo sapete come fece?
Mandò una delle guardie naziste,
che dissero: "chi è che vuole
incontrare la sua mamma? "
E allora Sergio fece un passo avanti,
e fu l'ultima volta
che videro il loro cugino.
E allora emorroidi, bianco.
Belle sono invece le more
raccolte a Srebrenica
fra popoli che cercano
di trovare una strada comune;
i murales delle truppe dell'Onu,
con le donne violentate, no.
Ho visto anche quelli,
ma quelli non hanno
proprio niente di bello,
se non la possibilità di poter raccontare,
e denunciare come un`ossessione
in qualsiasi ritrovo pubblico.
È la denuncia la bellezza,
il ricordo di ciò che è stato
perché mai più accada.
Bello è il capretto nel piatto
che mi hanno offerto dal campo rom
che sta a 200 metri da casa mia.
Che a me non piace neanche il capretto,
figuratevi quello cotto
intorno a una specie di palo
rubato da un cartello
stradale, lasciato solo,
e girato su un fuoco
fatto di legna e plastica:
soprattutto di plastica, in quel caso.
Un invito a cena che non potevo rifiutare.
Cioè, l'avrei potuto rifiutare:
ma che lo rifiutavo a fare?
E poi quando balliamo,
a un certo punto di quella serata,
io sgraziatissimo,
in quella piccola roulotte
che era diventata una casa per quattro
e un ospite: in quel caso, io.
Bellezza per me è anche riuscire
a smascherare certi revisionismi.
Certi fascisti.
Certi pezzi di merda,
e scusate la ripetizione
ma non la parolaccia.
Bello è il marito
che dal cellulare mette
le musiche abruzzesi
e poi poggia il cellulare
sulla testiera del letto,
per provare a ballare con la moglie.
La moglie è in coma da 15 anni,
e lui tutti i giorni la andava
a trovare, prendendo il treno;
e io l'accompagnai.
Lo faceva tutti i giorni
fuorché però la domenica,
perché la domenica i figli non lavoravano,
e allora andavano con lui in auto.
E allora ognuno ha un'idea
diversa, differente;
la mia ad esempio
è molto diversa dalla sua
rispetto al fine vita:
ma quanta bellezza c'è
in quel ballo con le mani, gliele prende
e il cellulare con le musiche
abruzzesi che loro ballavano
quando anche lei poteva stare in piedi.
Belli sono gli angoli,
belli sono gli anfratti, i pertugi,
certi particolari di poco conto,
le "ritrose" all'azione selvaggia
del pettine sono belle.
Quelle che si sottraggono
all'idea di qualcun altro
che per dispetto le chiama "ritrose",
e invece si stanno semplicemente
facendo la vita loro.
Le "ritrose", nella mia terra toscana,
sono anche quei capelli
che quando ti svegli la mattina
sono quel ciuffo che non riesci
ad addomesticare,
che ci butti su un fiotto d'acqua
ma tanto giù non ci va,
e riesci ad abbassarlo
solo tenendoci la mano;
ma appena sposti la mano,
il ciuffo va per conto suo.
Me l'ha ricordato stamane
anche Domenico Santoro.
Le ritrose sono l'idea
che ognuno possa fare come vuole,
e prendere le direzioni che vuole.
E questo somiglia molto alla libertà,
e la libertà è la cosa
più bella che noi abbiamo.
Belli sono i grazie:
"grazie" è davvero la parola
più anticapitalista del nostro vocabolario
perché la si dice con grazia
quando non abbiamo
più niente da attenderci,
quando i patti sono stati già rispettati.
Non è un contratto,
è l'ammissione di aver ricevuto qualcosa
e di voler rendere "grazie"
a chi abbiamo di fronte.
Per questo, questa sera,
io ve lo dico con il cuore
e con tutto l'affetto di cui sono capace:
grazie!
Siate benedetti dalla vita
e moltiplicate le sue bellezze,
che per sconfiggere le genti brutte -
che quasi mai vengono dal mare -
serve soprattutto
allargare la prospettiva,
prima che cambiarla renderla più ampia,
includendo perciò
anche quelle degli altri.
Genti di tutti i tempi,
siate rivoluzionari,
siate belli e siate belle.
Grazie e buona serata.
(Applausi)